[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a derek chovan trial juror faces new
scrutiny over questions of impartiality
was important information not disclosed
during jury selection
what mr uh mitchell has done is he's
given
more fuel for the appellate fire
the ohio man on trial accused of
murdering his roommate and burning the
body to cover it up
but was it killing in self-defense he
told lie after lie
lie on top of lies the officers being
hailed as heroes for rushing a 13 year
old shooting victim to the hospital
in the back of their cop car stay with
us he was in and out of consciousness so
we're trying to keep him alive and keep
him up
and check out the moves on this
so-called freestyling felon
why police in florida say his
celebration might be short-lived
plus dramatic testimony as a man
describes being shot in the head
and surviving day two of the wisconsin
trial of joshua eight
i've seen that uh
my nose here and i just go down and
try to get away law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
questions are being raised about the
objectivity of one of the jurors in the
trial of derek chauvin
after a photo of the juror wearing a
black lives matter t-shirt
surfaces angenette levy looks at what it
could mean for the verdict
yeah brian brandon mitchell is really
the only juror who actually deliberated
who's spoken public publicly about the
verdict
there's a facebook post that's
circulating that's raising questions
about whether or not mitchell should
have ever made it on the jury at all
is everything that you answered on that
questionnaire true and correct
yes that was prospective juror number 52
during jury selection
we now know he's brandon mitchell
mitchell's uncle posted a photo of him
last august on facebook
mitchell is wearing a t-shirt marked get
your knee off our necks with a photo of
dr martin luther king jr
and blm mitchell was asked about his
feelings about black lives matter
during jury selection i don't know black
lives matter as an organization
okay that's i don't i don't know it as
an organization so maybe that's
i mean i don't know if that's how the
question said i don't know if it said
black lives matter organization i don't
i don't view it as that so i don't
that's not how i subscribe to that
mitchell said he could be impartial and
wanted to be on the jury because it was
a historic
moment former federal prosecutor gene
rossi says the facebook post
could be problematic the t-shirt to me
if i'm a defense attorney for derek
shelvin
the t-shirt to me suggests that he
thinks that the person
who took the life of george floyd should
be found guilty
mitchell told a minneapolis tv station
the photo of him is from a rally in
washington dc
last summer that commemorated dr king's
i have a dream speech
and george floyd's family spoke there
briefly but he would have attended even
if floyd hadn't died
mitchell spoke to law in crime last week
manslaughter figured out right away
third degree took maybe three and a half
hours
and then the second degree murder we
figured out maybe 30 45 minutes
former hennepin county public defender
mary moriarty says judge cahill could
hold a schwartz hearing
at the request of derek chauvin mitchell
would be questioned by the judge about
his answers on the questionnaire
to see whether he tried to hide
attending that event would the defense
have
tried to excuse him because he
participated
if they knew that he participated in
this march commemorating martin luther
king
or is that just another piece of who he
was which was
fairly clear i think in the
questionnaire and in the questioning
and if that's the case the the judge
would not declare a mistrial
i reached out to brandon mitchell and
have not yet heard back from him
his questionnaire remains sealed by the
court as do all the other juror
questionnaires
and it's not clear whether or not
defense attorney eric nelson will
request one of these schwartz hearings
i've reached out to him and the attorney
general's office in minnesota
and neither one have gotten back to me
brian
thanks internet joining us today is
criminal defense attorney gigi gonzalez
and terry austin
gigi if he lied on the questionnaire
then i can see nelson having grounds for
an appeal
but mitchell said he was favorable to
black lives matter but could be
impartial
is that not the ultimate question here
exactly
and you know i don't know if he actually
lied on the questionnaire because
mitchell says that he was attending
the voter registration rally and not the
protest
so unless the question was phrased as
something like
were you at any protest or uh similar
activities
and he lied about it then maybe nelson's
got a shot here
but you know it seems that mitchell was
fourth right in his position with black
lives matter
and that really is uh to the crux of the
point here so
i don't know if this would be successful
on appeal based on what we know right
now
now terry nelson have peremptory
challenges he could
have gotten rid of of mitchell and
surprised it even made it but the court
could also argue that well
you could have removed them with one of
your challenges and you did it could
that argument be
fatal for the defense i think that the
judge or the court could ask that
question but i don't think that's the
real
issue because the real issue is whether
or not there was jury misconduct and
whether or not
he lied during the voir dire or the
questionnaire on the questionnaire he
checked the box and said
he really had no opinion about black
lives matter during the
questioning in the border he said the
same thing and
at the demonstration you know he had a
t-shirt and he says that it was because
it was
for martin luther king so i don't think
that this is enough for a mistrial i
think
it could be viewed as all very
consistent statements
no anjanet are there any particular
responses by mitchell that you think
could help sherwin's defense
and trying to get a mistrial here you
know i don't know if any of this is
helpful
to the defense there may just be such
overwhelming evidence in the court's
mind or the appellate court's mind that
they'd feel like
this wasn't that big of a deal and it
wouldn't have changed the verdict had he
been stricken
from the jury pool but it is interesting
though that
this t-shirt surfaces it is talking
about the knee on the neck and get your
knee off of our necks
and that really is a statement that
emanated and originated from the death
of george floyd so
you could construe it as what as you
know
advocating for the position that he did
cause or he believed he did chauvin did
cause the death but
he did say he could be impartial so
it'll be really interesting to see if
the defense actually pursues this
yeah and angela you bring up a great
point there of harmless error that this
could have been an error
but the overwhelming evidence could have
been so much that it kind of covers up
that error that's another great point
thank you all and be sure to tune in to
the law and crime network this friday at
9 00 pm
for an hour-long special on the derek
shogun trial hosted by our very own
angeannette levy
still ahead on law and crime daily
what's the man that's the man who shot
me
one wisconsin shooting victim's
impactful testimony in court
but first was a suicide note fate the
question
for an ohio jury in the case of a
dismembered roommate next
welcome back an ohio man accused of
killing his roommate and burning the
body is standing trial for first-degree
murder
56-year-old joshua whitaker was reported
missing on july 25 2020
but deputies at the hocking county
sheriff's office quickly realized he
hadn't been seen in weeks
investigators believe his roommate
michael dixon shot whitaker
cut his body and burned his body parts
over several days
the defense says dixon saw whitaker
pointing a gun at his 18 year old
daughter
melody sue dixon and their client fired
in self-defense
melody sue dixon is charged with helping
her father cover up the murder
michael dixon is also charged with
sexually assaulting his daughter melody
sue
the first responding deputy says he
became suspicious when whitaker's
daughter handed him what appeared to be
a suicide note
took pictures contacted the detective
after i had been there
only after about 15 minutes i did not
have a
positive feeling about the case
and then after speaking with them
i also received a letter from
julie she gave me a letter that was a
sample letter that she identified as her
her father's handwriting she had digital
photographs
of something that she was claiming was a
suicide note that was allegedly written
by her father
she had that digital format and she so
that wasn't her father's handwriting and
she
emailed that to me and i received that
the following day on the 26th
so i wanted to have something that she
identified as a
known um item that she identified as her
father's handwriting
to have as a possible comparison in the
future
on cross-examination the defense asked
the lieutenant about the extent of his
involvement in this case
if you said that you're there for about
two hours total that is correct and that
during your time there you didn't see
anything out of the ordinary
correct outside of the pictures you took
that's correct okay
and you said that the only time you'd
seen mr whitaker was in 2018
yes that was about two years prior to
this correct
so you have no idea what he looked like
really in those two years just from what
you've seen earlier
yes okay did you have any other
interaction with mr whitaker
no do you know anything else about him
or his home or anything of that nature
no i do not and after this two hours you
were involved
was that pretty much the totality of
your part of this investigation that's
correct
and the last thing was i imagine that
when you were sent out there on this
missing persons you probably looked in
to see if there's anyone else who had
made a missing person's report from mr
whitaker um
i did not specifically try to search for
someone who had made another
report of that okay but you weren't
aware of anyone else who had made any
previous reports that mr whitaker no it
was not
back with us as criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and terry austin
terry this is a crazy story self-defense
i'm not sure if it's going to work
but how crazy would it be if melody sue
testified
that she was under duress and that she
was actually being attacked by whitaker
could that help out
the dixon case well i think michael
dixon is not going to prevail on a
self-defense but we'll have to see what
the evidence says
i do think the daughter will be able to
say that she was
under duress and was helping her father
really take care of the body
and hide the corpse or burn the corpse
or get rid of it in some way
she has to show really basically that
there was a threat that
she might be killed and in fact she
feared for that
and there was no other way for her to
escape so i think she's the daughter
there's nothing else she can do
she could claim that she feared for her
life and that's why she helped her
father cover this up
yeah that second trial be interesting to
watch gigi it's the gigi gonzalez
dirty hands but not bloody hands defense
uh admit to the dismemberment but not
the murder
could it work in this case i don't think
so brian and in order for him to make
that defense fly he's to have to testify
and that's going to open up to some
nasty cross-examination
we'll have to answer why didn't he go
ahead and report the killing
uh who wrote that suicide note uh
there's a lot of really brutal questions
he will have to answer for
that i just really don't see him doing
that well on the stand so
for those reasons i do not think that
the uh dirty hands but
no bloody hands will prevail here yeah i
agree the defense would make more
sense if you killed the man trying to
harm your daughter
and then you just called the police
afterwards i don't think there's a
single person
who would disagree with that argument
who would feel a different way about it
but as you pointed out the note the
uh the chopping up of the body that's
going to make a little messy
we'll see how that defense works out
coming up on lawn crime daily hero cops
out of chicago
how two officers saved a 13 year old boy
plus
one suspected felon may have celebrated
his crimes a little too early the video
you don't want to miss
on the other side of this break
we're back two police officers in
chicago are being held as heroes
for saving a 13 year old boy's shooting
victim
officer julius gibbons says he was out
on patrol with his partner last week
responding to a report of shots fired
when they were waved down and told a
young man was shot
we rerouted to the backyard and across
the street we saw a young man waving his
hand saying that he was shot
we rushed over there he told us his age
was 13 years old
due to his injuries we knew that time
was of the essence
that's when the duo jumped into action
picking the teen up and carrying him to
their squad car
we have to go about 100 200 feet
carrying this kid back to our squad car
and officer ward did a great job
carrying them the entire way officer
given stayed with the teen in the back
seat
as officer rhonda ward drove them to the
hospital
stay with me and we gonna make this trip
together
and he trusted us and
we wanted him to and we made it we got
there
right on time for him that was the main
goal
and that's the only goal we had in hand
and we wanted him right there with us
because we due to the trauma i know it
man it was a lot so we was like man stay
with us and he did just that
so he's a hero too the boy is in stable
condition
and is expected to be okay
terry quick thinking by these officers
know these heroes
hopefully save this young man's life
what did you think when you first saw
the story
you know brian we need more stories just
like this one and i'm sure they are
out there the police are sworn to care
and to protect and they did just
that and you know i heard officer
gibbons say
that the age of the victim had something
to do with his feelings and
it shows that he has empathy for the
people that he's serving and
rhonda ward the other officer who drove
the car and drove the young man to the
hospital
she basically said that's why she became
a police officer to save lives so i
think this was a great story and i'm
glad we were able to cover it
exactly so do i now to the sunshine
state where florida man strikes again
police are asking for your help to find
this so-called freestyling felon
police in port st lucie want to speak to
sean gazzo and carl jackson
they say the pair were hired by an 86
year old to move heavy furniture
but stole ten thousand dollars worth of
jewelry they're accused of pawning the
jewelry
and that's when police say gaza
celebrated a bit prematurely
detectives say gaza can be seen here on
surveillance video outside the pawn shop
dancing in the parking lot gazo and
jackson are wanted for dealing in stolen
property and theft
gigi i'm looking at this as a defense
attorney can you imagine the lineup
video in this case
the officer comes on uh number four can
you dance for me please
uh yes officer that that's the man right
there
what did you make of this smooth
criminal video
well you know what this smooth criminal
he may be a smooth criminal but he's
definitely
bad not michael jackson bad just bad bad
and let me tell you st lucia does not
play with your defendants they throw the
book at them so
if this judge catches a glimpse of this
defendant's moves uh she's sure to throw
the book
at him too because they were not pretty
yeah and it looks like it could be id
quality video from inside
uh the pawn shop but of course i don't
think anyone's gonna mistake
those dance moves ever again gg thank
you very much
when we come back one victim of an
apparent love gone wrong shooting takes
the stand
the compelling testimony out of
wisconsin in just a few
welcome back testifying before the man
accused of trying to kill you that's
what one wisconsin man did in court on
tuesday
hey he's shot okay hey let's get back
here let's get you back here get back
here get back here come on
john miller was shot in the head august
4 2020 as he was trying to fix a car
and he looked at her
and i was doing something
and then he turned around and shot me
okay
miller was helping his friend's daughter
rebecca browkowski repairing a car
so she could return it to her
ex-boyfriend berkowski called it quits
after dating 39-year-old joshua aide
for five years the car was the last
thing that tied them together
have you ever met their daughter that
day no
that morning i know not at all
i mean i knew they had four four kids
believe
and you agreed to do that just as a
favor
yeah yeah in court miller identified the
man who shot him
as joshua aide i turned and there was a
red thing staring at me and i just
went down like that and got shot in my
face
and the man that you saw come up the
driveway
and that shot you in the face do you see
him in the courtroom today yes i did
examination the defense asked miller if
he had a weapon and about his criminal
history
you had armed yourself with a knife
prior to going to
rebecca's house that afternoon correct
no
your testimony that you did not have a
knife on your person that day i may have
had a box cutter night on me and i used
to be carried i may have had that
so he did have a knife on you
[Music]
at the start of your testimony you
testified that you had quote
about and quote 13 convictions you have
actually 13 convictions correct yes
57 year old miller was a friend of
brokowski's father james gruntner
miller and brokowski survived the
shooting but gruntner was pronounced
dead at the scene
eight is on trial for murder and
attempted murder the oshkosh wisconsin
trial is set to last one week
let's bring terry and gigi back one last
time to discuss the joshua aide case
now gigi not one but two survivors
testified in this murder trial
and as you and i have discussed outside
of the show homicide trials are hard but
attempted
homicide or attempted murder can be even
harder because you have an
actual victim take the stand now how
powerful was the testimony here
in front of the jury incredibly powerful
again these are victims with personal
knowledge of who the defendant is
they had a personal beef with the
defendant and saw the defendant commit
the act
the jurors are going to weigh their
testimony uh very much and it's
probably going to be the most powerful
evidence that they deliberate over here
now terry it seems like the
prosecution's got everything they've got
the gun
they've got eyewitnesses they've got a
great theme
that i think everyone can understand
that being the disgruntled
uh ex-boyfriend or ex-girlfriend uh it
seems to be pretty
uh well following line for the
prosecution uh this trial is speeding
along
with all of those facts do you see a
quick deliberation in this case as well
you know what brian this trial has gone
so quickly the witnesses have gone up
and down faster than i've ever seen
before
i actually think that the deliberation
could be longer than the trial itself or
at least
longer than the prosecution's case there
was a lot of
evidence presented and these are very
serious charges
homicide attempted homicide i think the
jury is going to take their time
they're going to go through the evidence
and there's a little bit of doubt
here in terms of whether or not there
was this extra gun
that was on the premises and so i think
they're going to want to look at all of
that and consider it
and it could take a little while for
them to come back with the verdict of
guilty or not guilty
and terry you heard there on that
cross-examination the defense
asking the witness or the complaining
witness
in that cross-examination about whether
or not he had a weapon
on him what did you make of that cross
examination and the response by the
by the witness said he had a box cutter
or something of that nature
you know brian that's where the doubt
will come up he should know whether he
had a knife or a box cutter
that's not something that you forget
about and so i definitely think that
he's raising some doubt and i think it's
something that the jury is going to
think about whether or not
this was in self-defense or whether or
not this was just cold-blooded murder
yeah we'll see how that works out three
against one the one having a gun we'll
see how that self-defense plays out
gg terry thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you